to survive the Esports winter once
valuable franchises had three choices
this year get smaller get together or
get out in May 2022 at what might now be
considered the peak Forbes estimated at
least 10 Esports organizations had
reached valuations above $200 million
with TSM topping the list at $540
million today teams are likely worth a
fraction of that the downturn started
with several uncontrollable factors
including fears of a recession drying up
sponsorship and VC funding or in the
case of TSM the cancellation of a
10-year $210 million naming rights
agreement with FTX after the crypto
exchange's founder Sam bakman freed was
arrested for fraud the most public black
ey for the Esports industry has been the
implosion of fazeclan which went public
through a spa in July 2022 and saw its
market capitalization top $1 billion
Last Summer the stock soon plummeted
when public filings showed that FaZe was
blowing through money at an alarming
rate and in October the company was
acquired by games Square the Jerry Jones
backed gaming company in an all-stock
transaction at a valuation of $17
million elsewhere Sentinels a Los
angeles-based Esports organization with
teams in Halo Apex Legends and valerent
had to turn to a crowdfunding campaign
in July after reporting 222 revenues of
$2.4 3 million against $1.13 million in
expenses
filing documents stated the company had
enough cash on hand to operate for only
2 to 3 months if it could not raise
additional funds the campaign's target
goal was to sell $1.23 million in equity
at a $30 million valuation by offering
enhanced fan experiences such as an
exclusive varsity jacket or meet and
greets with the players despite the
intense Financial hardships of most
teams fan interest in Esports continues
to rise organizations Count Their
successes by follower and view counts
selling invest investors and sponsors on
the promise of reaching a desirable
young audience the difficulty of course
has been to find ways to monetize these
highly engaged fan bases unlike
traditional sports teams Esports
organizations don't benefit from ticket
and Concession sales from dozens of home
games or the multi-billion doll media
rights deals that have sent team
valuation skyrocketing in recent years
in Europe and Asia Esports franchises
are far closer to viability but that is
largely because a lack of access to
investor dollars them to grow slower
over the past few years in the United
States new entrance flush with VC cash
made splashy player Acquisitions driving
up salaries across the board depending
on the game players retain 80 to 95% of
tournament prize pools and also get to
keep whatever personal content Revenue
they earn by live streaming or creating
videos now in order to bring costs into
line Esports player salaries have been
reduced in estimated 30 to 40% on
average according to Industry insiders
as 2024 approaches Esports team owners
believe the next year will bring further
consolidation as teams reach the end of
their VC Bank roles and test investor
patience to continue funding money
losing operations in 2024 Esports team
Motors believe the year will bring
further consolidation as teams reach the
end of their VC Bank roles and test
investor patience to continue funding
money losing operations but most remain
optimistic that the dollars will
eventually follow fan interest and the
industry will correct its Growing Pains
[Music]